welcome to the man of recaps this is
ozark season four part two the final
season we left off with ruth langmore
having an epic meltdown because javi the
new cartel leader had just killed
darlene and her cousin wyatt hobby and
the birds have a meeting in chicago to
finish the deal with claire shaw of shaw
pharmaceuticals but ruth follows him
there and crashes their dinner you're
gonna help me kill hobby and they can
see there's no talking her out of it so
they lure hobby back to claire's office
and blam oh ruth kills him and this is
bad for the birds the deal with javi and
the fbi was done they were out but now
they've gotta scramble again their new
plan is the same as their old plan
they'll just use omar navarro instead of
his nephew hobby but getting him out of
prison will require some serious
political capital behind the scenes
politics is wendy bird's specialty
working with her guy jim rattlesdorf
problem is a lot of their power came
from the shaw pharmaceuticals deal and
now claire's scared she's backing out
the next problem is the cartel won't
wait for navarro to get out of prison
they need to re-secure his power now
someone has to go down in person and run
things as his proxy so it's marty bird
mild-mannered midwestern dad here to
intimidate all the cartel lieutenants
and he does a decent job it's like look
omar killed hobby he's still in charge
and i speak for him so you listen to me
someone doesn't take it well though and
tries to have him killed in prison but
navarro survives and now it's up to
marty to do what navarro would do and
interrogate and kill his top suspect now
marty made a new friend here javi's
mother and navarro's sister camilla but
soon he realizes she's the one who tried
to kill her brother because she thought
he killed her son hobby but wendy bird's
like yo let's not tell him for now let's
see how this plays out now when marty
and wendy disagree this season they
don't have their classic blow up fights
they just stew in silence but with
everything more intense than ever you
can tell they got a lot of pent-up anger
ruth meanwhile is looking for a new
friend so she flies to miami to recruit
an old one rachel from the blue cat
turns out because her cousin wyatt
married darlene who had no heirs ruth
now inherits the snell fortune she tears
down the trailers gonna build an awesome
new lake house she actually gets her
criminal record cleared and is ready to
start a new life and she buys a majority
stake in the missouri bell casino sorry
marty it's a hostile takeover but no
hard feelings but wendy's not gonna let
that happen she sends the cartel hitman
to just go scare her but she warns
rachel who is staying at your place and
so when he shows up blam oh it's rachel
who kills him and ruth's happy no crime
new life starts with a dead cartel
hitman buried under her pool and now
it's time for bird family dinner to
check in on the kids one of the kids
anyway charlotte bird is happy with her
parents these days and has no issues but
jonah's still mad at his mom and is
living in the motel and there's yet
another new problem with all the
attention around her brother ben's
disappearance now wendy's father's in
town he's hired the private investigator
mel saddam who was looking for helen
pierce last season now to find ben and
her dad seems like a stand-up guy who's
all about god and is sober now but wendy
hates him he was awful to her and turns
out he's still got a secret drinking
problem and is an awful dude now this
investigator is really good at his job
he figures out wendy had a cartel hitman
kill her brother it's only a matter of
time till he gets some real proof so the
birds have to bribe him to drop it by
getting him his old job on the chicago
police force back but now wendy and her
dad have a blow-up fight he's like hey
kids why don't you come stay with
grandpa for a while and they're like
yeah maybe that's for the best but
wendy's not gonna lose her kids she
pulls a classic mom move and checks
herself into the mental hospital to
guilt-trip him ruth and wendy haven't
been getting along but they bond over
having bad dads so she goes down there
and exposes his hypocrisy to the kids so
they go to see their mom who gives them
a pretty good apology for being too
controlling lately and the bird families
back together including ruth langmore
marty's protege who at one point they
considered part of the family she and
the birds had been at odds lately but
now she's back ready to be friends but
now if the scene of the bird family
happily driving seems familiar it's
because it was the scene from the
beginning of season four that teased the
massive car crash turns out though
they're all totally fine the car crash
was just like symbolic or whatever now
back to the cartel the birds decide to
side with camilla i think it's time the
cartel had a girl boss so in a prison
transfer gone wrong camilla has her
brother killed by navarro and third
time's the charm as the birds facilitate
a deal between the cartel and the fbi
this time with ruth and rachel part of
it laundering money through the missouri
bell legally for the fbi and now with
camilla on their side wendy's able to
scare claire shaw back into her deal so
now the bird family foundation is a huge
success and wendy did it she's the
behind-the-scenes political queen of the
whole midwest so it seems like
everything is good happy endings all
around but before she had him killed her
brother told her the truth that he
didn't kill hobby and now she wants the
truth she threatens claire very
explicitly and claire shaw has no
particular loyalty to ruth langmore so
she gives her up she's like hey birds i
know you and ruth are tight but i'm
gonna kill her and if you warn her i
kill you too so the birds start
scrambling how are we gonna save ruth
but there's just no way to do it you
knew this had to happen when it comes
down to it will marty sacrifice ruth to
protect his family and he does and so
ruth langmore arguably the real
protagonist of this show this close to
getting a happy ending but instead with
a curse on her lips she is killed and
meanwhile the birds who got her into
this mess get everything they want
scot-free to tie up loose ends with some
minor characters [ __ ] mama's boy real
estate guy lost his mother and his
inheritance and a stripper wife and it
now gets baptized he's found jesus and
don't forget ruth's other cousin three
who was barely in the show but now has
lost his entire family but will be rich
and as for marty and wendy's marriage
well it's saved this whole ordeal has
actually finally brought him together
they say they love each other and are
gonna stick it out but we're not done
yet there's one more problem when mill
sat on the investigators in their
backyard he came back when it dawned on
him the goat cookie jar has ben's ashes
inside dna evidence and the birds can't
bribe him this time he's not gonna let
him get away with this so it's up to
jonah bird with the shotgun every single
season he's pointed a shotgun at someone
and this time his parents give him the
nod and when it cuts to black glam and
that's where ozark comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]